hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my vixen episode for video
another Barry Oliver episode and a bunch
of Easter eggs from arrow season 3 and
flash season 1 so here we go this
episode was really picking up where the
first episode starts them chasing her
down seeing how her powers work and then
learning the distinction between dark
matter metahumans like the metahumans as
the people on the flash think of them in
naturally occurring metahumans makes it
even teases the idea of magic she's like
I think the abilities that I have
they're magic so we're just getting
started there they're gonna deepen that
a little bit because yes technically she
is a metahuman but her abilities or more
mystically based so just expect to hear
more and more about magic when they talk
about the totem the really fun stuff
though is all the Easter eggs so you
probably noticed some of these but here
we go just going down the list so first
up she runs up the building just like
Barry during flash season 1 if you
remember that episode they actually had
to do the calculation as to how fast
Barry had to run so that he could run up
the side of the building you know with
that without falling down
so vixen going very very fast now then
she gets the classic all of her line I
know I know I failed my city I feel like
any time the Oliver character goes on
anyone else's series now they're
obligated to say that like it's written
in the contract must say the line from
season 1 Oliver makes a joke about the
metahuman prison you just throw them in
your pipeline prison I'll be really
interested to see what happens with that
in season 2 like they're still gonna
have to capture metahumans and keep him
somewhere but as of the end of season 1
all the metahumans that were in there
before have broken out that was what
that whole Captain Cold episode was
about why did you let them go so they'll
owe me one then there's the legend of
the olicity fern continuing on if you
don't remember or you don't know what
people are talking about when they talk
about the fern this is like an ELISA T
specific thing at the beginning of arrow
season 3 we learned that Oliver had been
living in the arrow cave Felicity
brought him a fern just like hey I
brought this to brighten up the
atmosphere and the fern became a
metaphor for Oliver and Felicity's
relationship so just charting the path
of the fern a little bit its sat in the
arrow cave for all of season 3 Felicity
makes the joke about being the one to
water it so you remember when everyone
thought that Oliver was dead and in
Felicity was crying for most of arrow
season 3 the fern actually stopped
getting watered and it looked like it
was super sad so it became more of a
literal metaphor for what was going on
in Felicity's head then when caity lotz
came back to do legends of tomorrow
stuff between seasons you know they did
this funny fern shot just using the
cut to the arrow season 4 trailer where
there's a fern in front of the house
where Oliver and Felicity have been
living so The Legend of the fern
continues and the fern continues to get
bigger and bigger so Felicity has been
presumably watering it this whole time
so that's what people are talking about
when they talk about the olicity fern
it's just like this ongoing inside joke
speaking of which another ongoing inside
joke in the DC TV universe big belly
burger
turns out Morrie McCabe on the night of
the particle accelerator explosion was
inside a big belly burger drinking in
icebergs shake they used to have a big
belly burger set on arrow but I think
they tore that down to build their
lazarus pit set in on the flash there
was actually a deleted scene from
episode 22 I think where Caitlin is
going to feed the metahumans that she
has like a truckload of big belly burger
so some cool flash arrow Easter eggs we
finally get to see felicity guest star
and we meet our villains at the end of
the episode now we don't know who this
is
it could be someone that's related to
vixen because it's her family that's
usually chasing her down trying to take
the totem from her in the comics if you
saw my last vixen video usually explain
that in the comics it's the uncle that's
the villain of the story but they might
have just swapped him for a cousin in
the cartoon you guys can let me know
that like what was your favorite moment
from this week's episode like which joke
about arrow and the flash did you like
the most it's fun to watch her use all
her powers but really the fun thing for
me is just noticing all the little arrow
flash Easter eggs and everyone's
wondering about vixen going on the
live-action shows like crossing over
with air in the flash in real life I
think it's gonna happen but they haven't
announced anything specifically the
actress McKellen is definitely down for
it she's just waiting for them to give
her the call please come be on arrow in
the flash in related news if you guys
didn't see it I just posted a new flash
trailer so I'll put a link in the
description but there also might be some
new arrow footage today if there is I'll
totally do a new video for that be sure
to subscribe to get everything and also
in that flash video I posted yesterday I
talked a little bit about the reverse
flash ring giveaway that's just gonna
continue till the season starts so white
guys wait for everything you can click
here for my latest flash trailer video
and you can click here for the last
arrow trailer thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight